T
NG TO TRUMP TO
NO INCITELENCE. I WANT TO
BRGVI
LEGAFORMER GER, SUCH
CLKE, THANKSROU TT AC
NIGHT. WHY TGE J LTH PARTICULARK
PRESIDENT TRUMPANDS THA
THIS IS AICAL A GEORGENDED MHAST
HE, GE
D TO ALNG. IT WAS
GEGE
ALVIN BRAGG'S
PRIOR MANHATTAN DNED TPRHE A AR
WHEN ALVIN BRAGG WORKEDHE
ATTORNEY GFFE THAT T
ATTORNEYEC TO PROSECUTEGES
ELECTION COMMISSIOECNEESRGES.
ALVIBRD TO
TSEE
REF THE TOPHEROM THHEN ALVIN BRG
OFFIS FROM THE BEN
HE WAS IE NROFFI T TCO REVIV TSD
A .  B
OLRUMP. AND TH H
N'S THAT AASSESTHE APAR OF IMPAT
PPEARANCE THAT THISOT BE IMPARTP
A LOT THERELETEN FT, C
W F ALL I BONDS
ERAYD THATORS OF FEDERAS ASKED E
SO THO AECROUGHT
WE'RE TALKINAB TS , RIGHT?
OUROHISONLY HOURS TUD
PRESEN SAIDERSTANDINI VTHESIDENS
ALLY IEOL
INST SS WERERITICIZIENTAU H
DEMOCRATS WERE ILLEGAL
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICEPAIGNS
SUHS S RM THATAMSS
ATTEMPT AGAINST JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH, HIWIY, AND
DGHOT
HE DEMOCRATICBUT THAT'S THA
NOT EVEN WHAT I'M ASNG YOU SO LD
T TRUMP HATI
JUDGET R WAS
FORMER PRESIDE A FER,UDGEOML , E
ERS. YOURSTRIE
THIS  WITH TRYINGOHE
HAEARANCE OF BIASH IT LOOKS LIKE
DONATED TO JOAM GET TAS A HISTOH
PRMPPRIOR CASES,
THAWH PRESIDENT
TRUMPRRING TO.E
IS NOW MOVINWH O
CT TMPTEAM?
MUCH AS CAN
T TT'S A IT'SOKE OFT ALL. IA TTE
LV IS CLEARLYICAL
HI.  C MATTH
COLANGOTHE BI JUSTICE
DENT TO USERF
LOFTYE TO GET TRU
TO WE SHOULD NOTE
ONE OF THE TRUS JOE,  SAYS TH .
AND WHAT EVIDENCE DO
IN THIS
CONSPIRACY THAT FORMER DOJ
ACYLOYEE U
AGAINST TRUMP? WHATARDOUHER ITH
JUSTICE AND TINER, ALVIN BRAGG A
DOOLUIT HIS JRE
JUSTICDENT ANDOCKEDAL BRAGG SMAD
DISCUSON THATMMAN SPOSE THOSE
STINTWEMICHELANGELO. DO YOU THIT
NEW YO WHEN YOU HAVE THE
THESE LOCAL MANHATTAN
JUDG HAD A
REPUBLICANR A YORKAND 17 YEARSNR
TO WN HAVE A 95%T  TRUMP. Y KNOI
. WHAT?YT
TH5%RE THROWIN LSTUFF
THERE. AND I JUSG WHATOK UP YOK
. SO A MILLION DOLLARSTT
WE KN TTHIS CASE WAS DEAD.
HDEORGE
SOSAVA RS TO
A PROGRESS PCOULD
BACKPACK GAVE HALF A
NOLLARSNNEF  WASMA FOR
THER COM. ER TT
AHEAD. THAHE
RK PACYOU'RE TALKING. THERE AERD
FACT CHEGT SOOU
FUND BOGUS
POLITICAL CHARGESVE
A THIS CASE WON TRUMP'S OPPONEN,
JOE BIDEN. SO YOU TELL METH AAIT
THAT. Y? WHYIDY THAT?
THEN? ARE YOU
NOT TMP. I DON'T HAVE
GO STAND ION
JUDG EAY. I MAYBE JOE
TO MOVE THE VEOM
A HAVE TOH ED BIDEN C HENT
STANDARD IS APPEARANCE OFIANPP S
WH T J
TO JOE BIDEN, PRESIDENT TRULITIT
IF TRUMP TO HIS M F FOLLO
'R B D TO EN SOON, BUT
YO IS ALLOWEDYOU'REMPN TE PUBEDT
IID
IT WAS CAN'TTI, I T THINK
TO RIKERS ISLAND'S? IS THEGEESD
, E' HERE
THAT TRUMP WASEF
WE SHOULD NOTE
HEN HE WASREPUBLICAN, FIRST AJUR